yeah welcome to this video playing black
guest player within US flag let's play
the lockin again got a sec ok now you
can read this in multiple ways and we
got two to four nights with a 3m a 3 is
a tricky move the ideas of the Bishop c5
to to play the two to take on them only
5 mm i still wonder i recently wondered
if this is really so great and usually
they say after a three you should play d
60 B should be seven months and what
passive news okay let's let's let's see
that you will take otherwise this is
pointless and now I think they go F for
you and I wondered about this if this is
really so great for a white ok d5 can
maybe maybe d6s them is the issue here
if i go to d8 you may be placed d 6 cm
now this could be the real problem
hmm mmhmm yeah what should I do taking
on d5 is just good for water okay we're
not much choice I guess d6 is the
problem
takes on f6 Bishop f6 is okay this
doesn't trouble black but d6 yeah
probably playing Bishop c5 wasn't the
wisest decision but I was wondering
about this sound recently if this is so
so terrible but maybe it's d six years
the problem there's a similar position
with the bishop on b5 and the four
nights Rui four nights Bishop b4 b5 on
move foreign then Bishop g5 but then
that is a bishop on b5 which which is
really a bit a bit term different at
least he's taking some time which
surprises me because D 6 is pretty it's
pretty clear that this should be the
move and maybe you can try to to to not
take anything okay it takes them this
didn't look too too too threatening to
me to be honest now is this is yes / f4
I mean f4 is not particularly great
moves in this position at least that day
it seems that way okay may probably
wants to play Nigeria can I can respond
I can respond them even with h6 now can
it just develop and try to check okay
just wants to take this is surprising
helps me to develop I know two bishops
but it's not not so clear how he is
going to play against that what I'm just
doing not see five and Bishop f5 my
pieces have quite a quite decent squares
oh he loves me to take it how that see
more surprising now I get excellent play
the light squares are really weak whites
light squares efore in particular this
wouldn't be anything if we have the porn
on on f2 or let's say on f3 club it
matter but this is excellent them
excellent when the point is on f4 so
Bishop i wants to get the bishop to
deform hmm yeah that's that's actually a
good idea hmm haruki aid was sluggish
probably
but not not very precise
hmm yeah I should have played the plate
probably different water trying to make
it more difficult for him to play the
smooth it's still nice for me but not
not not a huge huge edge I'm click on
the e-file as well the term does it turn
does it really lead to anything that's
very questionable I could be our Creator
let's let's try that trying to isolate
isolate the d5 pawn
trying to improve slowly okay if yeah
he's preparing g-form you had opposite
colored bishops and game simply will not
win and I'm not not sure what else to do
hmm
wow you allow me to go to 22 just rook
takes what was what I expected he wants
to play on Bishop before I look T 1
securing this rather unimportant porn
I'm not sure that he really should have
allowed me to to want to enter here rook
rookie to hem is going King f3m Bishop
c4 and b3 so let's go here
now rupee for now winning the f porn I
think it's such a weird placement of
pieces that you cannot protect the F
porn check yeah the d5 pawn lure gets
lost as well I'm not sure maybe to keep
the ropes on so no need yet to exchange
looks check
okay after he has weakened c3m I'm going
to exchange rules it's also allows them
to play some some cougar moose time
morning okay yeah this doesn't make any
sense okay no it's no it's okay I
forgotten she's attacking that ah ok
yeah ok this is no gossip dead wrong you
could try to win on time grah our third
game drawn no it doesn't what a game not
winning this is really are breaking Wow
yeah yeah maybe I shouldn't have
exchanged looks this isn't so this isn't
so easy now in fact it is easy I can
just take off course and this just just
wins da porn yeah ok ah yeah just a bit
too slow a.m. this morning I mean not
not with them necessarily with the
playing speed this is also too slow but
just too slow and thinking no yeah he
made some some stranger strategic
college decisions especially I'm letting
this Bishop exchange I mean it's not
clear where it should go with it this is
just just giving giving me a big big
game the question is if I if I got
something else I mean here I'll
can I prevent Bishop e3 to deform only I
cannot probably I cannot okay it keeps
it keeps it keeps some things as clear
mean the five is weak but we had a an
interesting moment here he just he just
needs to take with the rook after that I
mean I mmmm oops I'm getting d5 but
still with the rooks exchange this isn't
isn't the win now in this is still very
dry this this allowed me to to activate
pizzas and after that I think it's it's
gone here yeah I should just win because
this is such a such a great piece
configuration that I win the F porn with
interest d5 is also over gone and also a
move that that's may be interesting to
notice is b5 to isolate the pawn that it
cannot so that it cannot be supported
with c4 this really make sure they
actually win this alright so thanks for
watching